foreign
I wanted to do a kind of view from 30
000 feet of where we are and I think the
the title of this section is some
stories diagnose a system which is
something long time viewers of Dark
Horse will have heard me say before but
I want to give a kind of refresher what
that means before we get to the specific
example diagnose the failure systems are
just no they diagnose the system what is
the state of the system right so
the first example of this is the
Evergreen story
um Evergreen what happened to us at
Evergreen diagnosed
certainly diagnosed the College of which
we were apart for 15 years but it also
diagnosed the university system right
something happened to us at Evergreen
which revealed a pattern that was common
across the academy but it wouldn't be
obvious how common it was for a couple
of years right
and so the story was really what happens
when professors who have an excellent
track record on issues of race sex and
gender
stand in the way of diversity equity and
inclusion initiatives because those
initiatives would be bad for the college
that they're part of right and in fact
bad for the people that they were
ostensibly designed to to help right we
saw in the Evergreen story exactly what
happens which is that a phony story of
racism
is generated and it is used to support
riots to force the hand of the
administration and the administration of
course uses this uh as a a bit of
Leverage to remake the college for their
own purposes right bloating
Administration Etc
so the Evergreen story diagnosed the
system by showing you by it's like
luminal in some sense luminol during the
uh the substance that is uh sprayed on a
crime scene that then allows UV light to
reveal uh where there might be blood or
bodily fluids right so some stories
function like that election fraud some
stories function like luminol they
function like luminal election fraud is
another such story right we can see by
the way the uh the Press has dealt with
the question of election fraud in the
U.S that uh effectively what we have is
no longer a press interested in finding
the truth but we have is a press that is
interested in the team sport of politics
that basically highlights the
possibility of election fraud when it
works against the team that they're
affiliated with and uh obscures it when
it works for the team
um that they are affiliated with right
so we can see we're Once Upon a Time the
idea that there could have been a
distortion in American election would
have been a tremendously important story
that would have been of interest to
anybody who was patriotic and interested
in the health of the nation now we know
that the Press has taken sides and they
will only look at the story or frankly
invent the story
in service to one team and not the other
and so both of your first two examples
uh Evergreen as diagnostic of the larger
system of higher ed and
um coverage of a less of election fraud
as diagnostic of Journalism at large
speaks to two systems
that are explicitly
supposed to be that in fact do not
function if they fail to be nonpartisan
nonpartisan is the shallow end of the
pool they excuse me they uh journalism
and higher ed broadly
explicitly needs to investigate means to
encourage the investigation of stories
such that the truth is discovered
and it feels like you're gonna go a
third place uh which I'm I'm betting is
going to be science which is the biggest
one of these if if science uh doesn't uh
if if what we are calling science
has a pre-drawn conclusion and there's
only one thing that you're allowed to
conclude regardless of whether or not
research was done or not regardless of
what the data say or don't uh then
you're not doing science any more than
you're doing journalism if you only
cover one side any more then you're
actually engaged in an act of of higher
education if you allow ideologically
motivated
people to draw attention away from you
doing something which is actually
antithetical to higher ed which you know
is in part as you said about bloating
Administration
well you're close you're what you're
suggesting is certainly included in what
I'm uh going after here the third
example my third example diagnosis a
much larger system and in fact I don't
think it's a system that has a name you
know we can talk about our global system
and that has a kind of a vague limit on
it but I would say we are all embedded
in a
nested hierarchy of systems right and
what covid did was diagnose the entire
thing and I'm afraid that what it has to
say is
uh terrifying frankly
um okay so then let's
um let me say that not knowing exactly
where you're going with that that you
can you can put the third thing in there
that's at the same kind of level that
that is science oh it's that higher ad
you've got journalism and you've got
science and you know
I I would not want to be the person to
rank the importance of science versus
versus journalism in a functioning
Society higher ed also being necessary
but uh you're you're then going to talk
about some umbrella thing that doesn't
even have a name it's so big and
amorphous but certainly there are
aspects of what happened in the last two
and a half years that reveal the what we
call science of many of the people we
call scientists are actually no such
thing oh yes I'm absolutely going to
suggest that one of the
subsystems that is diagnosed by covid is
science and it is beyond unhealthy at
this moment it's just embedded in a
larger Network and you know
I don't know whether science is more
important or less important than
journalism in a functioning system I
would say having a functional scientific
system and journalistic apparatus are
both prerequisites so the point is there
isn't a more important you need both
those things you know in order for your
car to function is the engine more
important than the transmission
um you know no you need them both to
work
um so in any case what I'm going to
argue is that among the things that
kovid has revealed
is that journalism is completely dead
right the fact is there are stories
inside of the covid story
that are just waiting for a journalist
to take them seriously to investigate
them without partisan commitments and
follow them where they lead huge stories
stories that in the world that you and I
were born into were not only the kind of
thing that would make a journalist's
career but they were the kind of thing
that altered history where journalists
revealed something and the powerful were
in no position to stop it and these were
the things around which history pivoted
and the fact that we've got these
stories and can see them we can name
them and yet there does not appear to be
a journalist who regards themself as
capable of pursuing it or that they are
ready to confront the kind of power that
they would have to confront in order to
pursue it is is very shocking so we'll
return to that but journalism is one of
the things that is clearly diagnosed by
the coveted story The failure of certain
stories to be systematically explored by
um you know not not even just a
journalist but some newspaper or
journalistic magazine that wished to
ascend to the top of that hierarchy
right could do so simply by pursuing
these stories if something else weren't
uh
taking priority to your precedence yes
yes
um the second thing is exactly what you
mentioned it's science
we are I think
living in a dark age I think that has
been
arriving for some time I strongly
encourage members of our audience who
have not listened to my conversation
with Steve Patterson to to do so he and
I discussed the question extensively he
has a different approach to the question
of whether we are in a dark age but
nonetheless I think the idea that we
might be and that the evidence is
actually persuasive is something that is
um it's profoundly important because of
you know
is it more important than journalism who
knows but is it vitally important that
you have a functional truth-seeking
apparatus able to figure out what the
basic facts imply right of course it is
especially you know the more
technological and complex Our Lives
become the more important it is that
we're able to sort signal from noise and
figure out what we're doing that uh is
inflicting harm on us and what we might
do that would make us healthier and
safer
another system that is clearly diagnosed
by this is universities and it turns out
that whatever universities were
previously they have become effectively
churches that exist in service of a
particular team's articles of faith that
is to say they rationalize belief in
certain things that may or may not be
supported by any evidence right A Team
declares that something is true and then
the university provides what appears to
be science that suggests that it's true
irrespective of whether or not there is
an equally compelling or more compelling
body of evidence that suggests that it's
false right that is not the function of
a university as it has been defined
but it is the way that these things are
behaving
yeah and you can't claim that University
acting that way isn't a university I
mean you might but because University is
defined as a much larger and more
amorphous thing
um that's that's not the kind of claim
that I think you or I would make um but
you can we
can and will and have said actually when
you do it like that when you have a
foregone conclusion and you look for
evidence to fit that or to uh to analyze
in such a way data to analyze in such a
way that it can be made to look like it
fits
that's not science it's not science
right it's not science and the you know
it'd be one thing if it was just simply
not science but when it's dressed as
science and it's specific so it's
basically sucking up all the oxygen in
the room for doing science right and not
doing it that's lethal I've heard my
science for the week done the science oh
man yeah I so follow the science yeah I
followed so much science I was exhausted
I'm going after pizza man I'm saying
stuff
um
but
um
yeah it's well it actually suggests
something I've said in a very different
context
you know I've argued that the the
American Founders made an error for
which we can't hold them responsible
because of when in history they existed
they built an evolutionary system they
built a system that had all of the
necessary components for it to evolve
without building in a structure that
recognized that and uh counteracted it
right so the point is they built
something with the intention to create X
but because it evolved basically it
found a niche and became why which is
something being pre-darwinian they could
not have properly anticipated and they
did a hell of a job though oh they did
they did they far exceeded expectations
um given what they knew but given what
we now know the answer is look anytime
you build something with all of the
characteristics necessary to make it
evolve a you'd be a fool to think it
won't and B you have to do something to
deal with what it's going to evolve into
and the right thing to do
is to make sure that it can't find a
niche that does things that you don't
want done right so our system has
evolved into something without a name
and it masquerades as a Democratic
Republic and it serves some other
function and the universities are like
this too right the universities because
of the reward structure in them have
evolved to become this church-like
entity with sacred beliefs that cannot
be challenged with evidence right that
thing was inevitable that this would
happen but it results in this other
thing that we've talked about
extensively which is
the mismatch between the contents of the
box and the label on the box that's
right oh it says University on it oh
this must be a place of Truth seeking no
yeah it was at one time but it has
inverted its purpose right it's now a
truth obscuring entity yeah well I mean
this a lab coat is a kind of label I
said last week I think lab coats are
cheap labels are cheap it's a lot
cheaper to change what you call a thing
or what you slap on the outside of a
thing than it is to change the actual
thing itself right and it is also you
know a lab coat is a cloak and the point
is a cloak is an obscuring
um
uh entity it it obscures something and
so the point is if you were to invent a
universe something that does what modern
universities do
nobody we would spot it we would
recognize it as a hazard it is only
because it is dressed in sheep's
clothing that we don't notice what role
it is taking on well
disagree with you a bit here I don't I
don't see a lab coat primarily as a
cloak or a you know a wolf dress in
sheep's clothing I think
unfortunately what it is it's you know
it is the Insignia of I am you know I am
a Scientist and of course there's lots
of us who do science uh who don't do lab
science and so I have um relatively rare
reason to be wearing a lab coat but I
think for me you know I used to in the
beginning of my evergreen programs in my
like what is science lecture so you know
what do you need to do science read
glassware you need a lab coat you need a
PhD and of course you need none of those
things and this was the point but the
lab coat is this
um in premature it's this it's the
symbol
um that suggests that what's inside is
going to be a real scientist but
actually anyone can put on a lab coat
yeah well all right but then this
metaphorically this is particularly good
because if you think about what the lab
code is right where it came from
science is messy
you don't want to get it on you right
that's what a lab code is for right you
are going to be doing science and
whether that is Caustic chemicals or am
I talking metaphorically here no I'm
talking quite literally that science is
messy you don't want to get it on you
because it could be pathogenic it could
be poisonous it could be caustic it
could be a lot of things and so gross it
could just be gross but the idea that
this thing is supposed to protect
um what is inside and it is now become
its inverse it now hides what is inside
what is inside is now the dangerous
thing right and it is uh making it is it
is very much like like the metaphor of
sheep's clothing
um from the point of view of an
unsuspecting public that doesn't really
get that what makes something science is
this particular adherence to a method
and the philosophy that underlies it and
it is not the Walks Like a scientist
talks like a scientist thing which is
now very misleading yeah
yeah I guess I mean
this point it's going to feel very
semantic too
for a long time I think for me the the
main problem with the lab code is not
that it can obscure
um but that it appears the same that you
know that the the institutions of higher
ed themselves have become so corrupted
that uh the granting of the PHD that
enables you to have the lab that enables
you to have the lab code or you know
maybe it's just you know you're a you're
a lab tech in a lab and you're mostly
washing glassware but you still have the
lab coat many people will view the lab
coat as uh oh okay well then I'm gonna
I'm gonna ask that guy like because
because you're wearing the thing that
tells me that you have some kind of
authority and so it's it's the
it's the use of the lab coat as an
indicator of authority that I find to be
the giant risk and you know I mean and
he's too easy a Target at this point and
it's just remarkable to me how
politicized this has become the idea
that those who criticize voucher
inherently on the right is insane it
really makes the left look like a bunch
of baboons frankly and you know we're
not not all of us but you know fauci
claimed to be science on more than one
occasion and uh he ain't and he wasn't
doing it either he was a political
animal the entire time and maybe he was
a political baboon I don't know yeah
well I'm not disagreeing with you um I
would point out that the Milgram
experiment more or less exactly tested
this question that somebody was dressed
as scientists carried a kind of
authority that would cause people to
harm other people yeah
um but I would also point out what were
really you know go one layer down from
what we're discussing
and there is a an underlying truth which
is to the extent that something carries
special Authority it is going to be
targeted and captured and it's going to
be worn as a cloak right so what is the
New York Times it is the paper of record
except what it is now is some propaganda
rag that is owned by we don't exactly
know what and you know speaks their
sacred truths as if they were actually
true and so you know that should not be
surprising the fact that there was a
paper of record makes it an irresistible
Target for capture and unless it had an
incredibly good immunity of course it
was going to be captured and you know
likewise universities of course they're
going to be captured likewise Wikipedia
oh my God there's a free encyclopedia
that serves nobody's interest because
it's non-profit wow what a tantalizing
thing to capture and get it to speak
your particular propaganda
um because people take it as impartial
yeah right so basically the point is as
soon as you establish the thing that we
all need which is the voice that does
not pay any heed to people's Financial
interests or power
once you've got that thing you've also
put a bullseye on it right it's going to
be targeted for capture and if it if you
don't protect it then the point is it's
going to become your enemy
[Music]